Well, let's go through it together--our parse tree
is just going to be a list of elements, and here there are three:
hello, the tag element, and yaga.
And hello is just a simple Word_element
so it fills in our first blank.
Then we've got this tag_element and the
trick to getting this question right is looking
at the order in which we store them up here--
more or less in order of appearance.
So since this is a <bold> tag,
when this next part here is a (b),
this empty list means there were no particular arguments to our <bold> tag.
Here, I'm seeing arguments: color = "red".
There's nothing like that down here.
And then inside, we've got the Word_element, baba--and then we're done.
Baba Yaga was a crone or a witch in Slavic folklore
who was known for--among other things--
riding around in a house supported on chickens' legs--fun stuff!